- [Instructor] We're told that some boxes
of a certain brand of breakfast
cereal include a voucher
for a free video rental inside the box.
The company that makes the cereal claims
that a voucher can be
found in 20% of boxes,
however, based on their experiences
eating the cereal at home,
a group of students
believes that the proportion
of boxes with vouchers is less than 20%.
This group of students
purchased 65 boxes of the cereal
to investigate the company's claim.
The student found a total of 11 vouchers
for free video rentals in the 65 boxes.
Suppose it is reasonable to assume
that the 65 boxes purchased
by the students are a random sample
of all boxes of this cereal.
Based on this sample, is there support
for the students' belief
that the proportion
of boxes with vouchers is less than 20%?
Provide statistical evidence
to support your answer.
And so, like always, pause this video
and see if you can answer it by yourself,
and this actually is a question
from an AP statistics exam.
Alright, now let's work
through this together
and I'm going to try to model some
of what you might wanna do
if you were actually trying
to answer this on an exam.
So, the first thing
you might wanna say is,
well, what's our null and
our alternative hypothesis?
Well, our null hypothesis would be,
well, the reality is what
the breakfast brand claims,
that 20% of the boxes contain a voucher,
so that would be our null hypothesis,
and our alternative hypothesis
would be what we suspect,
that the true proportion of boxes
that contain a voucher is
actually less than 20%.
Now, if you're going to
do a significance test,
it's good practice to set
up your significance level
that you're going to
eventually compare your p-value
to ahead of time.
And so, let's say we would want to assume,
assume significance level,
so let me write this, significance,
significance level
alpha,
let's just go with 0.05,
and then we'll wanna
think about the sample.
And we're going to figure out,
if we assume that the
null hypothesis is true,
what's the probability that we get
the sample proportion that we do?
And if that is below
this significance level,
then we would reject the null hypothesis.
And so, what we know about the sample,
we know that we took 65 boxes of cereal,
n is equal to 65, they tell
us that right over there,
and from that, we can calculate
what the sample proportion is.
It's going to be 11 out of 65
and we can get our calculator out,
calculators are allowed
on this part of the exam.
And so, what is 11
divided by 65?
It gives us, and I'll just round
to the nearest thousandth, 169.
0.169.
0.169,
I'll say approximately
'cause I rounded it there.
Now, the next thing we wanna do
before we make an
inference is to make sure
we're meeting the
conditions for inference,
so I'll write this down over here.
Conditions,
conditions for inference,
and this is to feel good
that we have properly
sampling the population,
that our sampling distribution is going
to be roughly normal.
So, the first one is random sample
that is truly a random sample
and here they tell us.
It is reasonable to assume
that the 65 boxes purchased
by the students are a random sample,
so that checks that off.
So, I will just point that
to that right over there,
so that checks that off.
The next one is the normal condition,
that the shape is roughly normal
and it isn't skewed dramatically
one way or the other
and in order to meet that condition,
the sample size times the
true assumed proportion,
and we're going to assume that
the null hypothesis is true,
and so, we could say that,
and we could even say that
this is the proportion
assumed in the null hypothesis.
That's what that notation would imply,
and if you're doing
this on the actual test,
you should explain your use
of notation a little bit more
than I might do for the sake of time.
But this needs to be
greater than or equal to 10
and n times one minus the
assumed proportion needs
to be greater than or equal to 10.
Well, let's see, n is 65,
so 65 times the assumed proportion is 0.2.
That is going to be equal to 13.
13 is indeed greater than or equal to 10,
so that checks off.
And then we would take n 65
times one minus the
assumed proportion, so 0.8,
and that is going to
be equal to, let's see,
that would just be 65 minus 13,
which is going to be equal to 52,
and that indeed is also
greater than or equal to 10.
So, we met that condition right over there
and then the last one is the independence.
Independence.
We aren't sampling these
boxes with replacement,
so we need to feel good
that they are less than 10%
of the population of boxes,
and they don't tell us that explicitly,
but it would be good practice to say going
to assume,
assume
more
than,
let's see, 10 times that,
650 boxes in the population.
Boxes in population,
population,
which would imply that n is less than 10%
or less than or equal
to 10% of population,
of population, which would allow us
to check off the independence condition.
And so, given that we've met
our conditions for inference,
now let's think about the
sampling distribution.
So, the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions
because that's what we're going to use
to calculate a p-value.
So, we know a few things about
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions.
We know that the mean of
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions is just going
to be the assumed true proportion,
so that's the proportion
from the null hypothesis,
and we know that the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions.
This is going to be equal to,
and we've seen this in
multiple videos already,
this is the assumed
proportion times one minus
the assumed proportion
from our null hypothesis,
divided by n, which in this case is going
to be equal to
0.2
times 0.8,
all of that over at 65.
Once again, let's get our calculator out.
So, we're gonna have the square root
of 0.2
times 0.8
divided by 65
and then close my parentheses.
I get,
so 0.0496.
So, this is approximately 0.0496.
Now, the next step is to
figure out the p-value
which we can then compare
to our significance level
to decide whether or not to
reject the null hypothesis.
And in order to calculate the p-value,
let's figure out our z statistic,
which is, how many
standard deviations above
or below the mean of the
sampling distribution
is the sample statistic that we happen
to get for this sample of 65?
And we have seen this in previous videos.
This would be equal to
our sample proportion
minus the assumed proportion
for the population in the null hypothesis,
so the difference between those,
and then divided by the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions.
This would tell us how many
standard deviations are we above
or below the mean of the
sampling distribution.
So, in this particular situation,
this is going to be 0.169
minus
0.2,
all of that over this
value right over here,
which is approximately 0.0496.
I can get the calculator out again.
And so, we have 0.169
minus 0.2,
so that's how far below
our sample proportion is
than the mean of the
sampling distribution,
which is the assumed proportion
from the null hypothesis,
assumed population proportion,
and then we divide that.
We're gonna divide that
by the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions,
so divide that by 0.0496
and we get a z-value of approximately,
'cause remember, this is using a bunch
of approximations right over here,
about negative 0.625.
So, z is approximately
negative 0.625
and so now we can think
about the actual p-value.
Our p-value,
which is equal to the probability
of getting a sample proportion
that is at least as low
as the one that we got,
so a sample proportion that is less than
or equal to the one that we got, 0.169.
Assuming the null hypothesis is true,
so we could say assuming
the null hypothesis is true,
which is equal to the probability
of getting a z statistic that is less than
or equal to this value right
over here, negative 0.625.
And now we can use our calculator
to actually calculate this.
So, what we can do is,
we can go to second distribution.
We wanna do normative, normalcdf,
so go to normalcdf,
and then our lower bound
is actually going to be,
we could say negative infinity.
Our upper bound is going to be negative,
so negative 0.625,
625.
This is, you could say a normalized
normal distribution here,
so we'll just go with all of this
'cause we're just thinking about
the Z statistic right over here,
click enter,
and then click enter.
And then we get, this is going to be,
lets say, 0.266.
So, this is approximately 0.266,
and so let's just make
sure what we just did.
If this right over here is the
assumed sampling distribution
of the sample proportions
where we are assuming that
our null hypothesis is true,
so the mean of our sampling
distribution is going
to be our assumed proportion,
what we're saying is, look,
we got a result over here.
This is where our p-hat
happened to be right over here.
What's the probability of getting a result
that far below the true
proportion or further?
So, this is what we calculated just now.
Now when you look at this, this
is almost a 27% probability.
When you compare our p-value,
we're gonna compare our p-value
to our significance level
and we see that our p-value
is clearly greater than
our significance level,
0.266
is clearly greater
than our significance level of 0.05.
What we were saying is,
if there was less than a 5% chance
of getting the sample
proportion that we got,
then we would reject the null hypothesis,
which would suggest the alternative,
but here the probability
of getting the sample
proportion that we got,
if we assume that the
null hypothesis is true,
is almost 27%,
and so that's well above
our significance level,
so we will fail.
So, because of this,
because of this, we fail
to reject,
reject our null hypothesis,
and from that, we can
say not enough evidence
to suggest
our alternative hypothesis.
And if you have time you might wanna say,
there's not enough evidence to suggest
that less than 20% of the boxes
have the free video rental voucher
that they talked about in the
original problem description.